>> Jennifer Abella:
Hello everyone.
I hope you can hear me.
Welcome to the National
Book Festival's teen stage.
I'm Jennifer Abella, a copy
editor at the "Washington Post."
Which is a charter sponsor of
the National Book Festival.
I'm a huge fan of YA books.
So I'm very excited to
announce our next guest.
Before we get started, a word
of thanks to our cochairman
of the festival,
David Rubenstein,
and the other generous sponsors
who have made this
fantastic event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
there's information
in your programs.
We'll have some time
after the presentation
for questions and answers.
There's microphones in
the aisles for that.
If you do come to the mic,
I've been asked to remind you
that you will be included in
a videotape of this event.
So what you say will be
recorded for posterity,
and it may be broadcast
at later date.
It's my pleasure to introduce
our next guest, Robin Benway.
Robin made a name for herself
with her first book
"Audrey, Wait!"
in 2008. And followed it
up with books such as her
"Also Known As" series.
And "Emmy and Oliver."
Her sixth book "Far
From the Tree,"
which I will admit made me
cry, is about three teenagers
from different worlds
who discover they are
biological siblings.
It earned her the 2017
National Book Award
for young people's literature.
She'll be signing
books, by the way,
at 1:00 p.m. this afternoon.
In all of her books, Robin
explores the lives of teenagers
with heart and humanity
and humor.
Please welcome to the
stage Robin Benway.
[ Applause ]
>> Robin Benway: Okay,
can everyone hear me
okay into the mic?
Thank you.
Thank you so much for having me.
This is my first year at
the National Book Festival.
And it's 30 years since
I was actually in DC.
The last time I was
here, I was 12.
And I was with my dad
and my grandparents.
We drove here from Connecticut
in my grandpa's Honda Civic.
He wouldn't stop for food
because he was old-school.
My grandma fed us Tic
Tacs in the back seat.
And I never ever thought
that the next time I would be
here they would all be gone.
And I would be here at the
Library of Congress and speaking
at a book festival with
the National Book Awards.
So I'm having a very
beautiful emotional experience
at your book festival.
So thank you so much.
Yes, I am the author
of six books.
I live in Los Angeles,
California.
My most recent book,
as you heard,
has made many people
cry, as they tell me.
And it is called
"Far From the Tree."
It is about three siblings
all of whom were placed
for adoption as babies.
The middle sister, they
don't know about each other.
And the book opens when the
middle sister Grace is 16.
And she herself gets pregnant
and decides that she wants
to place her daughter
for adoption as well.
And in doing so, realizes
that she suddenly feels
a very strong connection
to her birth mother
whom she has never met.
And she goes in search of her.
And instead finds her
younger sister Maya.
And her older brother Joaquin.
Maya was also adopted.
She was adopted into
a family of redheads.
It is very easy to tell
who the adopted child is
in their family.
And their older brother Joaquin
is actually half Mexican.
And so he was never adopted.
He wound up in foster care.
And at the point that the
book begins, he is 17,
about to age out of foster care.
And he is convinced that
he will never be adopted.
And he's doing everything
in his power to make sure
that his wonderful foster
family does not keep him.
So, like I said,
it's my sixth book.
And I always thought
that it would get easier.
You know, the more you do
something, the easier it gets.
Turns out, like many things in
publishing, that is not true
in the publishing world.
Each book has been
progressively harder.
Which I was not expecting.
And so usually, when I talk
about "Far From the Tree,"
I try to tell you a little bit
about the writing
experience of it.
Because, like I said, it's the
hardest book I've ever written.
And actually I thought it was
the death knell of my career.
That did not happen,
it turns out.
But I thought that
my career was over.
And I try really lift the veil
on what it's like
to be a writer.
And how many times you have
to start over and over again.
I think in our days of social
media and Instagram filters,
it's very easy to think,
oh, you wrote a book.
And now it's out.
And now you're going
to write another book.
And it's out.
And that's not always the case.
And I know growing up,
I never met a writer.
I didn't know anything
about being a writer.
So I always tried to say
this is what it looks like.
So, like I said, when I was a
kid, I wanted to be a writer.
I wrote my very first
story, it was one page long,
in a spiral notebook when
I was eight years old.
And I reread that story
more than anything else.
Because I couldn't believe
that I could actually see
the words again and again.
I had a rough time in school.
I don't know if bullied
was the right word.
But I was very sensitive.
And I would come home
at the end of the day
and rewrite my day
where I was the hero.
And the cute boy liked me.
And I basically say that I
wrote fan fiction about myself
when I was nine years old.
Which maybe is healthy,
maybe it's not.
I'm not sure.
But I loved writing.
But I didn't meet any writers.
My mom was a real estate agent
and my dad fixed computers.
I never had an author
come to our school.
And I certainly didn't know
about any book festivals
where I could go
hear authors speak.
So I was the type A kid.
AP classes.
You're going to go to college.
Writing is fun, and you
can do it on the side.
Because you need a 401 K. You
know, you need a real job.
And so I graduated from college.
And I became a book publicist.
I worked for Random House.
And I planned all
the book tours.
And it was the very
first time in my life
that I was around authors.
And I could see they
were real people.
Like when I was growing
up, I thought Judy Bloom
and Ann M. Martin, like lived
in a house on top of a hill.
Like they didn't feel like real
living breathing people to me.
And for the first time
I could see authors.
And so I started to realize
that maybe, I mean, not for me,
but certainly someone else
could maybe be a writer being
in this position.
But I could never
actually publish a book.
I couldn't even finish
a short story.
And, but I loved writing.
And from that job, I worked
at an independent bookstore.
Loved my indie bookstores.
I became a sales rep for a
really big textbook company.
And I was the worst
sales rep they ever had.
And I know this because
they told me.
And they said, you are the
worst sales rep we've ever had.
And they were right.
And I realized that I
was just sort of doing,
I was circling being a writer.
I was doing everything in my
power, but I wasn't quite ready
to take that step yet.
Because the thing with being a
writer was that it was my dream.
And if I, it was the
thing that got me
through all those bad jobs.
And all of those
days stuck at a desk
that I didn't want to be there.
And I would think, well, one
day when I'm a famous writer.
And it was the thing
that kept me going.
And the thing is about
taking that leap,
is that you might
lose that dream.
You know, if you, if
I couldn't achieve it,
what would I have
to look toward?
And so I was really
scared of doing that.
And then I hit a point in
my life where in the course
of a year my father passed away.
Grandmother passed away.
And I was diagnosed
with gluten intolerance.
Which isn't as funny
as it sounds.
Everyone likes to make fun
of my gluten intolerance.
And type one diabetes.
So I became insulin dependent
all in the course of a year.
And I just had a moment where
I, like, almost like the movies.
Like "The Matrix," where
everything just comes
into very clear focus.
I was like, I need to do,
I need to take the leap.
I need to quit this
job, sales rep.
They were happy to see me go.
And I was like, I have to,
I'm going to become a writer.
So I applied to MFA programs.
I'd never have a
problem applying
and getting into things.
Very, you know, again,
type A student.
Got rejected from all my MFA
programs on the same day.
So that was a fun day
at the mailbox for sure.
And I thought, well, I tried.
I tried. I, if I can't
get into an MFA program,
how am I going to write a book?
And someone said to me, well,
why don't you just
write the book?
And I thought, but don't
you have to go to school?
Like don't you have
to get a degree?
Don't you have to pay
$50,000 to write a book?
And they were like,
just start writing.
So I quit my job.
I took a young adult
fiction course at UCLA.
And I, the very, assignment
of that class was
write a first chapter.
And the first chapter that I
wrote is still to this day,
word-for-word, the first
chapter of my first book.
It's called "Audrey, Wait!"
It's about a girl whose
boyfriend breaks up with her.
She breaks up with
her boyfriend.
He's in a band.
He's a terrible boyfriend.
It was definitely the right
decision to break up with him.
He writes a retaliation song
about what a bad
girlfriend she is.
And it becomes the number
one song in the country.
And at the time I
wrote it, I thought,
why would anyone ever be
famous just for being famous?
That makes no sense.
And 11 years later that book
feels oddly predictive now.
But that was my very first book.
And suddenly the
dream was happening.
And I thought, oh, I did it.
You know, done and dusted.
Wrote a book done.
You know, this is my career.
And then I kept writing, and
it started getting harder.
And the metaphor that I
give is that you're still
on the tight rope, but you
just keep getting higher off
the ground.
You feel like you
have expectations,
and you have readers.
Which is the most
beautiful, wonderful thing.
And yet you want to make
sure that everyone is happy.
You want to make sure
that people are still
enjoying what you're doing.
So I wrote a book about
sisters with super powers.
I wrote a spy series.
If you ever write books,
I highly recommend
writing a spy series.
Because the research
is so much fun.
And I'm sure I have
an FBI file now too.
But it was all in good fun.
I wrote a book about
parental abduction.
By the time my fifth book
came out, it was 2015.
I had one more book
on my contract,
and I completely stalled out.
I was in a panic.
I was in a blind panic because,
just to give you an idea.
"Far From the Tree" should
have come out June of 2016.
It published October of 2017.
Which, when you're under book
contract with a major publisher,
is not a fun conversation or
several conversations to have.
But I suddenly found
myself unable to come
up with an idea or a story.
I started an idea, which
I don't talk about.
Because I always worry that
one day it will become a book,
and I don't want
to spoil anything.
So I had an idea.
And I was spinning my wheels.
And so someone said, you need
to get an Excel spreadsheet.
I am a writer because I don't
want to use Excel spreadsheets.
But I thought, okay,
clearly I need a jump.
I need a kick.
So I got an Excel spreadsheet.
And it said, you have to
write this many words per day,
you know, to finish your book.
And I was like, great.
Perfect. Finally someone's
telling me what to do.
And I was writing
1,000 words a day
so my little spreadsheet
wouldn't get red.
And I kept it in the black.
And they were the worst words
I have probably ever written
in my career.
It was like when you're
a kid and you have
to write a 50-word
paragraph or essay.
And you're like, it was
very, very, very, very good.
You know, it was padding.
And I got about 15,000 words
into this book, and I gave it
to my agent, who I've
known since 2006.
So she's brutally honest,
which is why I love her.
And she said, this
is not your book.
This is not a good book.
You are just circling here.
And that was crushing because I
had never not completed a book.
And I had never not
able to do that.
And meanwhile, my publisher
is expecting a book.
You know, it's 2015.
They should have had
a book by this point.
And so I went back, and
I worked on another idea.
And that one was spinning
the drain as well.
And I started to make
my peace with the fact
that this might be
the end of my run.
That I got five books,
what a miracle.
I, how lucky am I to
have written five books
that have been published
around the world?
No one should be that lucky.
And I thought, okay, like,
maybe I need to make my peace
with the fact that this
is going to be over now.
And I called my mom one night.
It was 5:00 in the morning.
And because she's my
mom, she answered,
where most people wouldn't.
And I was sobbing.
And I told her, I
think it's over.
Like I really think this
career of mine is over.
And she listened.
And then she said, no, it's not.
And I was like, mom,
you don't know.
Like, you're not
in publishing, mom.
Like, and she's like,
no, you're not done.
And I said, okay, well, that's
nice to hear, and I'm done.
And I had to send a
letter to my editor.
And a big e-mail,
which was crushing.
And I said, I don't
have a book for you.
I am so sorry.
I wanted to give back my advance
that they had paid
me for this book.
My agent said, you're not
because the paperwork
is a nightmare.
And I don't want to
do the paperwork.
So you're not paying
back your advance.
And I, it was, I always say the
worst heartbreak of my life.
It was the worst breakup.
The idea that this thing
I have loved for so long,
I couldn't hang on
to it anymore.
Like why don't we each
other the way we used to?
You know, I couldn't keep it.
And it was going, I
felt like it was going
to someone else who
deserved it more.
So cut to me in a parking lot in
2015 at Costco with my mother.
Which is still a thing you
do as an adult apparently,
is you're in a Costco
parking lot with your mom.
And I was listening to
a song on the radio.
It was a Florence
and the Machine song,
if you know Florence.
Which, if you don't, I
highly recommend you get
to know Florence
and the Machine.
It was a lyric from
her song "Cosmic Love."
And it, the line was,
a falling star fell
from your heart and
landed in my eye.
And I immediately, and I've
heard that song so many times.
So many times.
And so many times after.
And for some reason
that lyric made me go,
this book is about adoption.
And it made me think of a
birth mother having a child.
Placing that child for adoption.
And hoping that somehow that
child will carry the love
of the birth mother even though
that child may never know her.
And I owe Florence so much.
I owe her royalties
and residuals.
Because in that parking
lot I grabbed my phone,
and I typed out the whole
e-mail to my editor.
And I said, this book
is about three siblings.
And their names are Joaquin.
Maya. And Grace.
It was like they just arrived.
They took their sweet time,
and they finally arrived.
And I said, I want
to tell this story.
I want to talk about adoption.
And I want to talk
about foster care.
about siblings.
I think the sibling relationship
is one of the most beautiful
and maddening and frustrating
and lengthy experiences
of your life.
And so I wanted to
talk about that.
And I was like, finally,
I have an idea.
Great. I'm going to sit down.
I'm going to write the book.
And it stalled out again.
And I was writing it entirely
from Grace's perspective.
The book opens with her having
her child by, no spoilers.
By page two she's giving birth.
So I didn't ruin
anything for you.
But she started telling
the story.
And she was talking
all about it,
and I could not get
past page 100.
And it was another
heartbreak for me.
I thought, oh, here we go again.
You know, just that
sickening feeling
of this is almost over again.
And so I went back,
and I read it.
And I thought this is so boring.
And this is the most boring
book I have every written.
And this really, okay.
So now I was just resigned.
I was like, okay, this is over.
Why am I dragging nit out?
Let me just stop.
So I went to lunch
with a good friend
of mine to cry and lament.
And she said, you should go
talk to a friend of mine,
that he is a foster parent
who recently adopted two
boys out of foster care.
You should go meet with them.
So I did. I met with her
friend who is now my friend.
I met with his boys who were
seven and nine, eight and ten.
And we walked them
to karate class.
And the dad sat, and he talked
to me all about the trials
and tribulations and
beauty and heartbreak
of adopting these
two wonderful boys.
And on the way back from karate
class, the youngest one said,
do you want a piece of gum?
He meant the one
that he was chewing.
And I said, no, I'm good.
Thank you.
And then right up in front of
my face a little half piece
of chewed gum came up like that.
And it broke, it was, ironically
it was such a sweet gesture.
And it was so sweet that
he wanted to share this.
And on the way home, I was like,
Grace cannot tell
everyone else's story.
She can't tell her brother
and her sister's story.
They have to tell it.
The way that these boys have
to be able to tell their story
to me, Joaquin in the book needs
to be able to tell his story.
And I went home, and I saw my
neighbor who was a painter.
And he said, how
is your book going?
Which is a very brave question
for someone to ask a writer.
Tread lightly when
you ask that question.
And I said, well, I think I need
to rewrite the entire thing.
And he goes, well, that
sounds really hard.
And I was like, yeah,
it does; doesn't it?
Yeah. And I went home,
and I tore it apart.
And I tore Grace's
chapters apart.
And I flipped it.
And the second I sat
down to write my,
I wrote 3,000 words in an hour.
Which is not how I norm,
just so we're clear,
that is not my normal pace.
And it was like they had been
waiting for me to find them
in a very strange way.
Sometimes I have found that
characters can be very elusive.
Especially ones who
have secrets.
Grace is very up front about
the fact that she had a baby.
She was the very first person,
character to start
talking to me.
But Maya was very reticent.
And she was very angry.
And I started writing
Maya's pages, and I realized
that her mom always had a
glass of wine in her hand.
Her mom was always
drinking wine.
And I was like, what's
happening over here?
Like why are you drinking wine?
And I realized that
that was Maya's secret.
That she is hiding her
mother's alcoholism.
That she is hiding it
to protect her family.
And it's slowly starting
to destroy her
because she is unable
to fully enter
into her relationship
with her girlfriend.
Because she has no idea how to
be open and honest with someone.
And I would have never known
that if Grace had
told her story.
You know, Grace didn't
know that in the beginning.
And then for Joaquin, like I
said, he grew up in foster care.
He has a very, very dark secret
of something that has happened
to him while he was
in foster care.
And he did not tell me
that secret for months.
I could not figure out what
Joaquin was hiding from me.
I should stop and say like,
when I talk about these things,
my mom is always like,
but they're in your head.
Like what do you
mean you don't know?
Don't, you have to know.
And it is a very strange
alchemy of being a writer.
You are meeting people
and watching them reveal
parts of themselves to you.
And I feel like I have been on
this journey with Grace and Maya
and Joaquin for so long.
Like after the National Book
Awards, my very first thought
after like, oh my,
what just happened,
was I can't wait to tell them.
And they're not waiting for
me to tell them anything.
But when I was researching
Joaquin, I read an article
that said, it was
by, with an actor,
an interview with an actor.
And he said, every character
has something they're trying
to hide.
And something, and the closer
that they get to revealing that,
that's where the
tension comes in.
And I really clung to that as
I was digging around trying
to go find out Joaquin's secret.
And then I started interviewing
every single person I had
ever met.
If I heard that you were adopted
or adopted a child in the time
that I was writing
"Far From the Tree,"
I interviewed you probably.
I talked to adoption attorneys.
I talked to foster care parents.
I talked to social workers.
Former foster kids.
Adoptees. Talked to people
who had wonderful experiences.
And people who had had
absolutely horrific experiences.
I wanted to talk to
every single person.
Because a big part of what was
going on for me was, is this,
are these my stories to tell?
We talk a lot about it
in young literature.
Especially whose
story are you telling?
And is this your, should
you be telling this story?
And for a long time I tried not
to tell the story, as you heard.
I did not want to
write this book.
And the book didn't seem
to want to be written.
But the characters never left.
And instead they got
stronger and stronger.
And I had to start listening
to what they were saying.
And finally I realized that I'm
just going to write a draft.
I'm just going to
see what happens.
And if it's terrible, someone
will tell me, I am sure.
Hopefully before it hits
Goodreads and social media.
And I will know it's bad,
and I'll just scrap it.
And I'll figure out
my next step.
I talked to every single person
that I had ever met
in my entire life.
And what I started
to realize was
that I can't tell
everybody's story in a book.
And, actually, if I do try to do
that, the book will not be good.
You know, it will try to be
all things to all people.
And it will not be
what it should be.
I realized I had to
tell three stories.
I had to tell Grace's story.
Maya's story.
And Joaquin's story.
And those were the three
stories that mattered the most.
And so I tried to make them
as specific as possible.
And some people didn't see
themselves in the book.
You know, I've gotten e-mails
from so many people
around the country.
Some of whom loved
"Far From the Tree."
I've been taken aback and also
surprised that I'm surprised.
I've gotten a lot of e-mails
from women especially,
but men too, in their maybe 50s,
60s, 70s who were forced to,
I don't like to say give
a child up for adoption.
But in those cases they were.
You know, the time and the era
of where we were as a country
and a community,
there was no ability
to raise a child out of wedlock.
And so I've got e-mails from
them saying, thank you so much.
I'm looking for my child.
I'm looking for my parent.
I'm trying to find, I
can't find anything.
Your story gives me hope.
And that, it fills me,
I'm very, very pleased
that they have found that.
But I've also gotten
e-mails from people
who didn't see themselves
in the book.
And that breaks my heart.
As a writer, you want to
try to give everything
to every person that
reads your book.
You hope that they get a really
positive experience from it.
And sometimes they don't.
And I had to sacrifice that
for Grace and Maya and Joaquin
for their stories
to come through.
And I'm just so, I
always kind of feel
like your characters
find you and pick you.
And I'm grateful
that they found me.
I'm grateful that
they picked me.
I hope I did them justice.
And, yeah, the experience of
writing "Far From the Tree" was,
turns out it didn't
end my career.
I finished, the book's
384 pages.
I wrote the last
two-thirds in about 12 days.
I don't recommend that
if you ever write a book.
A lot goes out the
window when you're writing
that many pages in 12 days.
And I gave it to my publisher.
And I said, here you go.
And I started applying for jobs.
I updated my resume, and I
started applying for jobs.
Because I thought,
well, this was fun.
I finalized, I finished
my contract.
I did not violate
any legal rules
where attorneys are
going to come after me.
Here we go.
Time to move on.
And I'm going to
sacrifice being published
so I can save my
love of writing.
Because at the end of day,
if I can't go home and write
down 500 words in a Word
document or in a notebook.
Like I did when I was eight.
What's the point
of being published?
I had to hang on to
my love of writing.
And so I was ready
to give it up.
And I sat outside
in early September.
I was at my mom's
house, like always.
And I was sitting outside.
And I thought, fall is coming.
"Far From the Tree" is
going to be out in a month.
I'm ready to let it go.
Godspeed little book.
Notice that beautiful poem
by Billy Collins,
I forget the title.
But he says, go out and meet
as many people as you can.
He's talking to his book.
And that's how I felt.
Like, go. And the next morning
I was in front of my computer.
And Lisa Lucas, who is
the executive director
of the National Book Foundation,
she said, hey, the long list is
out for the National Book Awards
for young people's literature.
And I thought, oh, let
me see if I know anyone.
And I clicked.
And I was the second
name on the list.
And I, to this day,
like I start shaking.
I can't, my mom came running.
Because she clearly thought
something terrible had happened.
And I just, I couldn't talk.
And I couldn't type.
And I remember thinking, oh,
maybe I don't need to send
that resume this morning.
Like maybe this is
going to change.
And I became a finalist.
And I miraculously won
the National Book Award.
A goal that I hadn't
even set for myself.
My, oh, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And the only reason
I talk about that,
because I know there's a lot of
younger people in the audience.
And I just want you
to know, like,
when you're doing
something that you love,
it doesn't mean that it's easy.
And it won't ever be easy.
I'm working on a
new book right now.
And I'm like, what am I doing?
You know, the award
doesn't change the process.
It's still very, very hard
to meet characters
and write a book.
But I just, I wish I had
heard that when I was younger.
That it doesn't have
to be perfect.
You just have to do it.
And you can go and fix it.
And you will make it
the best that it can be.
And that is exactly what
"Far From the Tree" was.
It was a labor of love that has
earned me beautiful accolades
and words and e-mails
and letters from people
that I'm so grateful for.
And yet at the same time I
have to go write another book.
And I'm thrilled.
I'm happy to do it.
But I've got to figure out
how to do this all over again.
And if my history is any proof,
the seventh book is going
to be even harder
than the last one.
Which I'm very worried about.
But, yeah, I just, if you
are a writer or anything.
A painter.
An artist.
Whatever it is.
It's a hard process.
And that doesn't mean that
you're on the wrong path.
And if there's anything that
I could ever impart to anyone,
much less young people,
it's that.
That you, that's
the beauty of it.
That's the absolute beauty
of creating something,
is that you sometimes,
through all of that muck,
you find something
that's really perfect.
So I could talk about myself
for another hour and a half.
But are there any
questions at all?
And I think there's mics
set up on either side,
if you have any questions.
Oh, we have a volunteer.
Hi.
>> Hi. So I loved "Your
Also Known As" series.
What was the inspiration
for that?
>> Robin Benway: Oh,
that's a good story.
So my "Also Known As"
series is my spy series.
It is about a 16-year-old
safe cracker and lock picker.
This is a very embarrassing
story,
but it has netted me two
books, so I will tell it.
I lived in an old apartment
that had a really terrifying
basement storage area.
It was like something out
of a "Saw" horror movie.
You know, that bulb dangling.
And something skittering
in the corner.
And cobwebs everywhere.
And I was moving
out, and I realized
as the movers were
arriving that the,
I hadn't gotten all my stuff
out of the storage unit.
Because I hadn't been
down there in years.
And it had a Master
Lock like you would see
on a school locker on there.
So I ran downstairs,
and I realized, oh,
I don't know the combination.
I haven't been down here
in this terrifying space
for over ten years.
So I did what we all do
when we don't know what
to do, is I Googled it.
I Googled how do you
crack a Master Lock.
And ten minutes later
I was breaking
into my own storage
unit with a pencil.
Don't use Master Locks
because it can be very tricky
to break into.
And so I thought, well, I kind
of felt cool after I did that.
I was like, look at me breaking
into my own storage space.
And I thought how
fun would that be
to be a safe cracker
or a lock picker.
And that's where
the idea for the
"Also Known As" series
came from.
That's why Maggie is a safe
cracker and a lock picker.
And one of the opening, I
think it's the opening line
of the book.
It's been a while now.
But I think her opening like is,
I cracked my first Master
lock when I was three.
And it took me a few more years,
obviously, to get to that point.
But, yeah, so that's where
the inspiration came from.
Is me not writing down a
combination ten years ago.
This writing life, man.
Yeah, hi.
>> Since you've gone through
a lot of writer's block what,
I know you found it
a way differently.
Like you heard it
like out of the blue.
>> Robin Benway: Yeah.
>> But do you have
any advice for people
who are going through that?
Like a certain thing
you could try to do?
>> Robin Benway: Yeah.
I know there's always kind of a
divide in the writing community.
Is writer's block real?
And I'm very much on
the side of, oh, yeah.
Like, it is very real.
What I find, it's funny.
I have found sometimes
I have two blocks.
Sometimes it's finding an idea.
And sometimes it's
writing that idea.
And so for finding the idea,
you can't chase an idea.
You can't, the idea will
only get further away.
You know if I had been
sitting in that car listening
to the radio being like,
this next song is going
to be the inspiration.
I would probably
never thought of that.
It just sort of happened.
So I think a big part of
it is having the faith
in the creative process that
the ideas will eventually come
to you.
Having that faith is very hard,
you know, to be steady that way.
When it comes to writing ideas
though, I have found that,
when I am really stuck,
it's because that I have either
backed myself into a corner.
Like I'm a maze.
Or that I am very scared, and
I don't know what I'm doing.
And I'm very scared of what
I'm going to write next.
I have a hard problem every
single time I open the
Word document.
I'm like, this could be it.
Like the words might
not come today.
Or worse, the ones I
wrote yesterday are going
to be really bad it turns
out when I read them back.
And so I try to break it apart.
I try to take my writer hat off
and put my problem
solver hat on.
Which sometimes they're
the same hat.
And I try to look at
it and think, okay,
did I write these
characters into a plot point
that they can't get out of?
Is this the wrong way to go?
Do I need to back them up and
send them down a different path?
Or do I just need to get over
myself and write 1,000 words
and let them all be terrible and
delete them all out tomorrow?
But for now I'm just going
to write those words?
And sometimes it's
kicking myself in the butt.
And sometimes it's looking
at the characters
and figuring it out.
But, yeah, and sometimes
you just got
to be really nice
to yourself too.
Like writing is hard, and
it's lonely sometimes.
And you're with imaginary
people all day long
that sometimes don't
give you what you want.
And so sometimes you have to go
for a walk or listen to music.
Or talk to a friend
or pet your dog.
Or, you know, just sometimes
get out of that writer's space
and just tell yourself that
maybe today isn't the right day.
But tomorrow could
be the right day.
Yeah, there's a whole bunch
of tools in my bag that I try
to use to break down
writer's block, yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Robin Benway: Yeah,
you're very welcome.
>> Hi.
>> Robin Benway: Hi.
>> First off, I just want to
tell you, like, getting through,
like, the writer's
block and, like,
all these obstacles
you had to go through,
especially with going "Far
From the Tree" has been,
like, super inspiring.
>> Robin Benway: Oh, thank you.
>> [inaudible] question.
How do you know that an idea
that you have is going
to be a good one?
And it's going to follow
into like a story that is
like cohesive and real that can
actually be made into a book?
>> Robin Benway: Usually,
and this is what I found while
writing all the precursors
to "Far From the Tree."
Was these, I didn't
know the characters
in the books that I was writing.
And I was 15, 20,000 words in.
And I was still like,
what is their point?
Like what are they,
what does she want?
Why is she doing this?
And I couldn't meet her.
You know, I just couldn't
figure out who this person was.
And I feel like that was
a very big sign to me.
When I know that
an idea is working,
it's with the characters
start doing things
that I was not expecting.
And they sort of take
on a life of their own.
And, again, my mom's like,
what do you mean you didn't
know what they were going to do?
And the example of like
Maya's mom drinking.
You know, that was not a
plot point at all in any
of the initial thoughts
that I had about the book.
And they reveal things in that
way that is so surprising.
It's like they trust you enough
to let you see a
door into their life.
And it's, that's when I'm like,
okay, this might be working.
This might be working.
And sometimes you don't
know till page 200.
But what else are
you going to do?
Just keep trying to meet them
and keep trying to
write them, yeah.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Robin Benway: You
are very welcome.
>> Hi.
>> Robin Benway: Hi.
>> Do you find, like, writing
down ideas harder or just, like,
finding the ideas in your
head or, for inspiration?
>> Robin Benway: You mean like
once I, do I find it hard to?
>> Write ideas down
or to find the ideas.
>> Robin Benway: I find it
much harder to find the idea.
I have some friends that have
a notebook full of 12 ideas.
Like, one of my friends
was like, yeah,
I have an idea due
to my publisher.
So I'm going to go
through my notebook.
And I was like, you have
a notebook of ideas?
Where do you get one of those?
Like, can I get one?
Yeah, I don't get
very many ideas.
And when they do, it's sort
of like, like I was saying.
Like, how, will this be a book?
Maybe it's just an
idea of a book.
I just got one a
couple months ago.
And it slowly started
to happen in my head.
But I don't like
to write them down.
Because I feel like once
I write them down, to me,
before I'm ready to
start writing the book,
they lose a little
bit of their magic.
I really love the idea
of having that idea
and just sitting with it.
And, you know, while you're
driving around or talking
to someone or walking the dog.
You know, you sort of,
I let those ideas kind
of just roll around in my head.
And they start to maybe
get a little bit bigger
and a little bit more complex.
And then I don't
write anything down.
I'm not an outliner.
I write entirely by
the seat of my pants.
And we'll just see
what happens, you know.
Sit down, and it's me
and the characters.
And hopefully we'll
all get along that day.
Yeah, thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> It seems like many times.
>> Robin Benway: It's a low mic.
>> It takes a while for the
characters to come to you.
>> Robin Benway: Yes.
>> And then after that you spend
a great deal of time with them.
And you have these
emotions and connections
that develop over the time.
But how do you know when
it's time to let go?
And that the book is done,
and you've told their story?
>> Robin Benway: That is
an excellent question.
How do you know when
the book is done?
I think as a writer,
to me it's never done.
You know, I always
want to keep going.
Not only refining, but
I just kind of want
to follow them sometimes.
And see when are you guys
going to go to college?
Are you going to go to college?
Like, I feel like I
always know the very,
very, very end of the book.
For some reason I always
know the very beginning
and the very end.
And the last three words of "Far
From the Tree" are very
emotional for people.
And I knew those
last three words
when I first started
writing the first three words
of "Far From the Tree."
So I kind of use that as our
my goal post, sports metaphor.
Like I think those, I kind of
try to use those as my buffers.
And think, okay, write
to this end scene.
I feel like once you answer
the character's questions.
You know, once you put their
story on the page, I have found
that it sort of dries up.
There's nothing more
I could have put
into "Far From the Tree."
Like, I felt like everything
that people needed to know
about those three
characters they knew.
And to add any more
would just be for me.
It would just be
selfish, you know.
Like I can go write fan fiction
about my characters
on my own time.
But the book didn't
need those facts.
And you find that
through editing sometimes.
You find it through drafting.
You find it because your editor
goes cut these 200 pages.
These are unnecessary.
You know, it's sometimes
a community effort.
But I feel like a lot of writing
is trusting your instinct.
And that would be a
good example of that.
And honing it over time as well.
Yeah.
>> So I was wondering.
You were talking about how you
don't write any ideas down.
Do you ever worry about losing
your idea completely because?
>> Robin Benway: No.
Because they're so
few to round up.
So it's not like trying
to herd cats, you know,
where they're all
over the place.
Oh, the dream to
have that many ideas.
But, no, I don't worry
about losing them.
Because, again, they're
so few and far
between that they
tend to become books.
And I feel like, if I did lose
an idea, then it wasn't meant
to be a book in the first place.
You know, if it was supposed
to stick around it would have.
Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Robin Benway: You're welcome.
>> Hi. I noticed that
you, when you were talking
about your characters
going through foster care.
That you didn't necessarily have
that own personal experience.
>> Robin Benway: Yeah.
>> So how do you make it okay
for you to tell that story?
How do you go about deciding
and making that decision?
>> Robin Benway: I talked
to a lot of foster kids.
I talked to a lot
of foster parents.
I talked to social workers.
I tried to make stories
as specific as possible.
It was hard.
That, and the fact that Joaquin
is half Mexican was incredibly
scary for me to write.
I think, I gave it
to beta readers.
I gave it to friends.
I gave it to people who knew
what I was trying to do.
And I feel like at the end
of day you just have to hope
that you gave it your best.
Not only with your brain,
but with your heart as well.
And that people will be
able to see themselves.
And not, again, not
everyone will be.
And it, sometimes that leap of
faith, again, of being a writer.
You hope that you
were good enough.
And I think in some cases I was.
Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Robin Benway:
You're very welcome.
I'm being told to wrap it up.
So thank you so, so much
for excellent questions
and for listening.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]